so I won an Emmy here's what that day
looked like I landed in New York two and
a half hours before the Emmy started and
I was filthy because I had been hiking
and Reporting on a story in Switzerland
for two weeks and I hadn't showered I
also didn't have any clothes for the
Emmys so first stop was h m to grab
something to wear I snagged a bunch of
clothes most of it off the sales rack
and headed to my hotel where I had about
45 minutes to shower and get ready
before heading to the Emmys and then I
had a random thought about bacteria
living on my body because I followed
John Green on the internet I know that
there are trillions of microorganisms in
my body at all time regardless of how
much soap I use here I am all ready to
go I hopped on a city bike and booked it
just in time to get to the Emmys I did
the Red Carpet thing I pretended I was
fancy or something but I was not
expecting to win until
States you're the problem the New York
Times opinion video The New York Times
accepting the Emmy
and then I got on stage and gave a
little speech so yeah that's how I got
this big shiny Trophy and feeling kind
of proud about it